the governor of florida chose an
evangelical church in the city of
kissimmee to sign the state's 15-week
abortion ban into law
currently florida allows women to have
abortions within the first 24 weeks of
pregnancy the new law comes into force
on july the 1st
the bill today will provide protections
for unborn children from abortion when
the child reaches 15 weeks of
gestational age of course these are
babies that have heartbeats and that can
feel pain
and can move as we said
there are some exceptions on health
grounds but no exception for rape or
incest abortion rights activists say the
law disproportionately affects the most
vulnerable
people with the fewest resources who
cannot afford to travel out of state for
time-sensitive
uh essential health care are forced to
carry pregnancies and go through
childbirth against their will the
consequences are devastating
several conservative states have
recently joined a growing push for
abortion restrictions
oklahoma's governor has signed a near
total ban the only exception is a
medical emergency
kentucky has also all but banned the
procedure new restrictions are expected
to force the state's two remaining
abortion providers to close
texas outlawed abortions after six weeks
last month a woman was arrested for
murder after being reported for an
alleged self-induced abortion though the
charges were dropped
anti-abortion activists are awaiting a
supreme court ruling on mississippi's
abortion ban pro-choice campaigners fear
the court stacked with conservative
justices may be ready to overturn roe
versus wade the decision that protects
federal abortion rights
access to abortions has long been a
divisive and deeply political issue in
the us
but momentum seems to be gathering pace
to challenge the choice of women across
the country
victoria gatenbee al jazeera